so i i'm hoping that you guys are are
able to understand these games even
though okay 2400 okay we're playing him
again
i don't mind that uh he's a good
opponent so that's totally fine with me
we can rematch
[Music]
same good that's fine that's fine i mean
at this level okay he's thinking so
so let's go um what should we do
all right let's just go e5 let's let's
see if he plays a rai lopez on us and
then i'll be able to demonstrate how i
play against the right lopez
he does okay so um
well the funny thing is i'm tempted to
play the berlin and i'm tempted to show
you guys
a little bit about the berlin because a
lot of people are very intimidated by
the berlin
and you shouldn't be intimidated by it
so i know people are rolling their eyes
at it
but let me demystify a little bit for
you guys why the berlin is so popular
what makes it so good okay he plays anti
berlin he plays d3
d3 defends the pawn that's the anti
berlin and uh
here the good thing for black
is that i actually can so this bishop on
f8
okay knight c3 is uncommon generally you
want to leave space
for the pawn to go to c3 so here we're
just going to develop our pieces
nothing nothing new under the sun we're
just going to play bishop e7 and castle
and after the game i'll give you guys a
little bit of a run down on the berlin
so he tries to do the same thing i did
in the previous game okay but bishop b3
is inaccurate
he should have followed this up with d4
this
is too slow how can we
make him regret this well d5
is decent but c5 is
a buzz or russian okay permanently
these are what we call the vampire teeth
i think we formulated a new term
someone in the chat did vampire teeth
are super effective at stopping
something
and now we can simply develop our pieces
without fear of him opening up the
center
what are the plans in this position well
we have one very classic plan in these
positions
which is to well we have the two let's
think about it this way we have the two
bishops which means
in general it would be good to open up
the position so eventually
what kind of move may allow us to open
up the position
and be careful because the move d5
is way too weakening way too weakening
because e5 is going to fall
out so the move is going to be f5 f5
ultimately we are going to prepare to
open the file but
and this is what i want people to
understand we are not going to hurry
with this
first i want to complete my development
okay and in order to complete my
development i want to bring the bishop
out to e6
but if we bring it out immediately then
he's going to play knight g5 so what
seems to be
a good measured healthy move h6 yes
that's also a good standalone move so
that's the logic we're going to develop
our bishop in
and then we are going to move the knight
and play f5 in addition we create an h7
square which could be used by the knight
but let's not even rush up five let's
see what he ends up doing
okay can we make any other improving
moves before we play
before we move the night away because
it's a good idea also to consider the
drawbacks of moving this knight away
if you think about the drawbacks of this
of moving this night away yeah queen d7
is a good move
one of the drawbacks is that it weakens
the d5 square so i like the move c6
knight d5 is not that dangerous because
we can take it
but why not reinforce it with a pawn so
we really don't have to worry about it
h6 is not that we know h6 is not
weakening that's only one
small move he's castled on that side of
the board so we don't have to worry
about him going
nuts with g4 okay this is he's grabbing
space but that's all he's doing
okay now we can we can play queen d7 we
can connect the rooks
but we can also get on with business
let's you know guys let's get on with it
let's move the knight away and play five
i think we've done
enough the reason i didn't play queen d7
is because i anticipate a future
and i want you guys to tell me what the
nicest space for the queen is now
we've done this before in many when we
play f5 a passageway opens up for the
queen
and this passageway is queen e8 queen g6
okay so we can play f4 and
attack king's indian style but i don't
see necessarily a reason to do that
quite yet
we can also go queen a queenie a queen
h5 get bingo
so we're trying to be flexible here
um knight h7 is also well we keep the
knight near the center i think that's
that's the bottom line
okay so let's get the queen into the
game
we are we are not committing to anything
here uh i will okay so he takes
what should we take with
and actually this is not a trivial
question
but um hmm
i actually like taking with the bishop
and the reason why is a very specific
one that i will explain after the game
because we don't have much time actually
he's threatening to force he's defending
super well
we are going to play now the move
let me think this is not easy
no sacking is not good
hmm
okay let's drop the bishop back let's
prevent let's prevent g4
let's prevent g4 and now ultimately yeah
that's why i'm moving the bishop back to
to undo the fork uh and how do we
how do we nurture our attack what how do
we bring pieces and there's a very very
classical typical plan in such positions
which allows us to bring the heavy
artillery in
and that is okay i have to make moves we
have to double up on the file so my
apologies here in advance guys i'm going
to play a little bit fast here
because this guy is you can see that
this guy is not
folding i mean that's one of the things
you see at this level is these people
have stopped
collapsing under pressure at least
collapsing immediately if we
continue applying the pressure then
eventually you'll see that he he might
blunder something but
um yeah we can work on though we always
have to keep in mind the sacrifice i
will show after the game why the
sacrifice is just very bad
okay so we can just double rooks we
don't need to do anything about this if
he takes on e5 gray he opens up the file
that's in our favor
there we go mana monarch thank you brian
okay so this is a bit of a trap move
because if we take on f4 the bishop on
e6
is undefended and he has knight takes d6
but
ding ding ding ding he's put the rook
and the
queen on the same diagonal so we can see
that bishop h4
is a possibility and i kind of blundered
knight takes d6
which would be a really i don't know but
then we take the rook anyway right we
attack the queen
now the point is that i want him to play
g3
i really want him to play g3 because
look at how much that would weaken
his king side we would just drop the
bishop back to where it came from
and then the queen would immediately
have access to h3 one of the
the key properties of any attack is
is this ability to introduce forcibly
weaknesses in your opponent's position
he's got a very five head move let's see
if he plays it
that move is queen to e2 okay so he does
sacrifice
uh now we do have to move the rook out
of the
the range of the knight so let's go rook
f6 maintaining the connection of the
rooks the rook can also swing as it will
to g6 now the rook repositions on
another very nice file
okay that is a pawn that we are going to
take to now open up the
now we have an extra exchange it makes
sense to open up files right
okay now it is a simple matter of
improving our piece placement marginally
until we find an opportunity to
capitalize now we do want to trade stuff
right i don't mind trading stuff now
um let's shift the rook over to d6 and
attack this newly created weakness
and uh let's dial the queen back to g6
in order to immobilize the rook
and let's blunder upon while we're at it
okay now i gotta focus a little bit
we've got not a lot of time
much much better here for black i should
be able to win this game
but um i want to make sure that i'm not
losing this one on time
yeah i'm giving up a little bit too much
here yeah this is not great
my technique here wasn't very good so
let me just try to pull this one out
guys
he's he's playing this extremely well i
have to say
these guys are just like insane like
beasts
yeah i might end up losing this one
actually i spent a little too long there
dilly dallying around
oh my god i'm blundering i'm i'm out of
gas completely just blundered a rook
yeah i'm gonna lose this one sorry guys
that was my
very bad technique
i mean this was this was coming
eventually
no but this guy is just playing game of
his life right now
oh oh and i oh my god i've wanted me to
i i didn't mean to make them
okay yeah he he picked up the
the pace after after after getting very
bad position
very nicely done what can i say
i wonder who this guy is okay
this guy is really strong so anyways um
essentially yeah i mean everything was
going well up until like
at certain at a certain point you just
started completely outplaying me
um yeah d5 was correct
so i mean basically everything here is
pretty clear
and then imperceptibly i started playing
badly
so bishop h4 is bad i mean knight d6
that was a misjudgment on my end
yeah d5 was was just winning here
d5 was just winning i mean knight g3 is
the reason i rejected this
but apparently after queen g6 black's
just got a huge initiative
like bishop h4 and okay g3 bishop takes
g3
and um this was a misjudgment and i and
here he played perfectly the rest of the
game i mean
every single move okay i mean black is
black is better here but my pieces are
all over the place
and um i got low on time
and uh yeah let's rematch him i want to
beat him
okay he's not on live chess
yeah g5
i mean probably i should go here
although it's already not that clear he
gets a lot of activity
yeah rookie six is good bishop d6 is
perfect
yeah d4 is the best move too i mean this
move i didn't understand completely but
apparently it's best
and then queen e3 knight c6 is best i
mean
he gave me absolutely no chances at some
point
so the bishop sack was just not good
enough i mean
what can i say guys he's he should be
3000. so queen takes h3
uh queen e3 and um
and and i just don't have any pieces in
the attack i just don't have any
pieces in the attack and um
maybe he's doing a speed run too
yeah i'm just gonna check this game and
okay he's back
he's back kudos to credit to him
no no he's he's legit he's just he's
just severely underrated
so let's go knight f3 and then we'll
analyze both
okay let's play the another alpha
okay so e5 is bad uh
and e5 is bad for a simple for for a
similar reason
well it's five am i i guess i should
also not underestimate my own
poor quality of play this weakens the d5
fun it also weakens this diagonal
so d4 just gives white an advantage
as we already know so cdcd
and um okay so he goes d5 himself
okay that's clearly some sort of
preparation so we're going to take on d5
how do we usually follow
follow up here
how do we usually follow up here
yeah knight c3 i guess he's got bishop
before but we can unpin ourselves with
bishop d2
we can unpin ourselves with bishop d2
the point is we're attacking his queen
we got the two bishops now
okay that's a free pawn i don't know
what he's doing
okay let's just develop with bishop b2
we're just up a pawn now i mean white is
much better
queen to e4 hmm
okay let's just keep developing with
castles
i guess rook d8 but then queenie won we
have to maintain contact with the bishop
okay queenie one we're up upon we just
need to untangle ourselves he's super
active
yeah he is very active here
hmm so how should we untangle ourselves
what do you guys think
so 92 blunders moving the night blunders
the bishop
yeah it's not easy i think we'll start
with
yeah he's a very tough opponent i should
probably focus
bishop d1 let's play bishop d1 let's get
the bishop out
because that bishop was the source of my
problems the bishop was very poorly
protected by the queen
okay so he takes the queen that lightens
the load a little bit and now we get an
end game where i have very weak pawns
all over the place but i am up a pawn
so this should be should be winnable
let's go h3
and now um let's go bishop
c2 or maybe bishop b3 is a better idea
uh contesting this bishop
okay rook d3 we need to defend the spawn
rook ac1
okay bishop h3 of bishop c4
hmm
no well black is much worse no he is
legit i mean completely legit
just very good h a6 okay so now we need
to improve our position
um and we can improve our position
in in a variety of ways it would be nice
to get rid of this rook
now bishop c2 is possible because rook
takes c3 we have a check
the problem with bishop c2 is i like
this bishop where it is
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go nitrify we're going to try to
force him to correct our pawn structure
our pawns are going to get braces for
free if he takes on b3
we're going to visit the orthodontist
and uh we we like visiting the earth i
mean
i don't like visiting the orthodontist
but pawns do
i don't miss the orthodontist but the
pawns do so knight f3
um now uh no no no no now let's move the
king out of the
well yeah let's move the king out of the
way
and now we're gonna go e6
now we're gonna go e6
yeah well i have nothing to smile about
i lost that game
now we're gonna open up the bishop
rook e8 okay we're gonna take it
this guy is good the reason this move is
good is now
okay now we must
let me think guys this guy is like
seriously good
craig tucker i know that but the point
of this is to be educational and i know
i know it's annoying to people but
normally i can
trust me normally i can i can explain my
moves against the 2400 and not get
outplayed so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to bring the king over to e2
and and try to try to kick the rook away
from d3
king e8 isn't is an odd move i don't
really understand it now he gives us a
chance to bring our king in
okay knight d2
okay rook a one okay four i'll analyze
both the last games i don't know
thank you gigahertz for the sorry i
missed that five gifted appreciate it my
man
okay now we're going to expand on the
queen on the king side with f4 and we're
going to try to
exploit our upon majority here
i mean it's very strange i mean it's
just i'm having a very hard time like
making progress against this guy
okay
defend the pawn
back to f6
it might be because it's 5 am
no i mean i'm allowed to compliment him
he is playing really well
i haven't gotten a plaque from youtube i
mean it's not that important to me
why compliment somebody on good play
we're going to tr okay g6 h4 we're going
to keep pushing the puns
he's not lucky he's honey h5 he finds a
way to inflect my pawns positively
however he opens the g
file
okay now we're going to tuck our king
over to c2
in order to buttress
okay this one here
i think we can go here and the bottom
line is that
we have a protected passer on c4
that is going to be very very strong
here
check oh sorry here he's going to check
me go rookie 3 probably
okay we need to win this fun otherwise
he gets connected passers
i think it's a draw unfortunately guys
oh this oh my god now i'm probably like
worse
c2 i mean
yeah i'm worse now i'm losing probably
although it's not clear it's not clear
what is king e5 you can now promote
takes takes nc3d7 c2 takes takes c63 f5
d4 takes it's winning
no it's winning now
okay i'm not implying anything but this
guy is very odd
i mean it intersperses yeah
that's a very strange move at the end to
not approach the punt
so let's let's look at the games guys i
won't stand for
any accusations um
i'm uh you know the thing is
it's a very tricky situation because
again i i always like to say this
ex nido imagine that you were him and
okay perhaps you're you're good your
rating doesn't reflect your strength
and then you watch the stream and you
have like 50 people cheating and you
didn't cheat
you just have this style and you just
played well
that kind of ruins your day so i don't
want to ruin this guy's day
now i'll be transparent in saying that
what is odd to me is the fact that
there is a huge delta between some some
of the moves he makes are terrible
absolutely terrible like not
characteristic of a 2400 at all
and then there are other stretches where
he plays extremely well
but that doesn't mean anything and
that's certainly not
grounds to conclude that he is cheating
and that's just what i want to make
clear so um
i i i get that people are not trying to
be disrespectful but
uh this is not called evidence that's
just something that's odd
okay so in this first game
right for example the smooth bishop e3
is um is just bad i mean d4 is the whole
idea
of taking on c6 that's the whole idea of
taking on c6
so by playing bishop a3 he allows us to
establish vampire teeth
and stop d4 i guess vampire teeth can be
good
to be fair guys uh let me make a couple
of things here since we're on the
subject i don't mind sharing some
thoughts on it
here's the thing um people cheat for a
variety of reasons and
you cannot accuracy is a very bad
indicator of whether someone is cheating
there are cheaters who
plug every move into the engine those
are the most obvious ones there are also
cheaters who
who will play you know a stretch of the
game with an engine then they'll turn
the engine off and they'll turn it back
on again
or they will turn it on when they get
frustrated at having a bad position
um there are also people who try to
disperse suspicion by playing the
occasional blunder
or they will deliberately make a
horrible move here and there precisely
to
disperse suspicion that is what makes
some cheaters so hard to catch
because it's a very fine line you also
don't want to falsely accuse people
um i think that some people imply this
guy fell into that category but
uh there are very advanced methods and i
do not have them so
in the absence of those methods it's
innocent until proven guilty
there is this and i i would call this
soft cheating
where people cheat and they still
maintain about the same rating
uh and i don't know really what is in
the minds of those people but
you know sometimes it's out of
frustration or it's the occasional
crutch it becomes an addiction i think
oh let me just check the computer here
let me just check the computer there
so this this categorical statement no
way a human plays that way i mean
do you know every human do you know what
goes on inside of his mind you can't
really say that there are moves which
you can say no women will play that but
you've got to be very careful before you
say that
i but i know that jimmy fallon and you
know the picture of jimmy fallon and
yeah
it's a little bit odd but at the same
time
it's just it is what it is so
in this game i think everything was
clear right and
let's try to understand when you lose a
game you want to get to the bottom of
what it is that went wrong exactly
uh and i did everything perfectly up
until this point
so i think that the the
um root of my mistake
and this is a lesson that i will
actually think about tonight
uh as i lay in bed is the fact that when
you see
a tactical property i just got too cocky
i did not stop to consider
the drawbacks of the move bishop h4
so yeah we are applying for a new mod so
the main mistake is that i basically
i didn't stop to consider the drawbacks
of the move and had i noticed that d6
would have been hanging
i would have played d5 that solves the
problem of the d-pawn
so after bishop h4 things just get very
very messy here
okay and then i made a series of small
mistakes to follow that up
and and lost the game in the end right
no i know you guys said d5 but
it's not that i'm not listening it's
just i i am making my own decisions at
the end of the day
some of you did call this move again i
thought after d5 knight g3
i wouldn't get a chance to play bishop
h4 now don't ask grandmother's rating is
that is a dirty secret
um so queen four queen g6
i guess the point is now bishop h4 is
super strong
yeah so okay
and uh after that things got very very
messy
and in the game that i won uh the
opening was very i mean it was odd
this move97 just gives the pawn up
that's another thing like
i don't know i mean at least play e
takes d4 or e4
and white is better in this position
because i've got the two bishops
but um this just gives the pawn up the
key move really here was to play bishop
d1
to identify what's wrong with the
position the bishop on e2 is super weak
and it's subject to attacks like knight
f4 so bishop d1
takes the bishop on a defended square
and this is to the point that not every
one of your moves has to be super
glamorous
right your moves have to be functional
they don't always have to be glamorous
um so you know
in this end game i kind of ground him
down but he played very very well
honestly guys i'm really tired i maybe
i'll i'll talk about this end game
tomorrow but i'll i will take specific
questions about this game
um yeah bishop d1 is hard to find
because it's a retreating move
retreating moves can be
invisible moves here i wanted to open up
the file basically and here i did
something very similar
to what i did in my first game against
him right remember this position
where i brought my king over to do
something the king can be the king is
like a mercenary
it can be employed for these small tasks
that may involve
uh the main mouth chasing the rook away
okay
so that's like the the bottom line right
the king is a
we can consider a weak piece but it's
capable of doing a lot of stuff
getting a lot of stuff done and uh here
we chase away the rook so that this rook
is then able to move
[Music]